[Music]
let's go to sarah in
the city of angels los angeles what's up
sarah
and not much how's it going we are
rocking on to the brick we're not i'm
just sitting here in a studio it's kind
of kind of being lame how are you
i'm good thanks
uh i have a question for you surrounding
our family identity um meaning what
should we call ourselves
um i hear you on the show you love my
nicknames is that what you're calling
for
i do i don't know what to call myself so
no
this our family name um so i hear you
talk on the show a lot about you know
the family values and drawing them up
and then you'll say things like we're
the dalonies and deloney's are people
who xyz yes um and we don't all have the
same last name
so i don't really know what to call us
and how to anchor those things and it
comes up in other ways too like what to
put on christmas cards and things like
that so why separate last names
so
um
sorry i get emotional about it no that's
cool man i'm glad that you called
it would have been way funner just to
come up with some nicknames i'm so good
at just
ruthless nicknames but that's not that's
not why you don't know why you're
calling so um yeah take your time no
problem at all so yeah why do y'all have
different names
um
so i'm married to my husband who's
wonderful and it's definitely the father
of all three of our kids but he's only
the biological father of our six months
old okay and we i have a six and eight
year old whose father died i'm so sorry
what was his name
dan dan
good guy
great guy yeah
when did they where when did dan pass
away
um almost seven years ago now seven
years ago that's still right there on
top of your heart isn't it
yep yeah how did he how did he pass away
um a heart arrhythmia sudden totally
unexpected oh man i'm so sorry
and so how'd you meet this new guy
um at work oh
gross he's wonderful we're all in love
it's great
that's so great i knew you're going to
make fun of us no i don't know
i'm absolutely not at all um
one of my most important men in my life
very similar situation he um married a
great woman whose husband passed away
suddenly just completely unexpectedly
and they have two wonderful kids and
there's still that
thing right that my life is because of
right and so
those are challenging just messy things
to walk through
and so you've decided your kids your
your two kids that were biologic
biological children of dan have kept his
last name
yeah
we're still really involved with his
family and that's important to them and
the kids have not expressed any desire
to change their last name so at this
point we're they're keeping their their
dad's last name their original dad's
last name and
i i just struggle a little bit i think
because i had my parents last name
growing up my husband had his parents
last name growing up and there's some
family pride behind it and to say we are
the let's say quote-unquote smith's
family yeah and there's something behind
that you know
how honest do you want me to be with you
brutal go for it come on sarah
not super brutal hey it can't get any
worse than the guy that you're you know
have kids with dropping dead on you
well played i see what you did there
um
i've talked to you for like two minutes
now okay
and
my impulse this is just from my guts
is that you haven't let dan go
and my guts is says
you have a picture of family
that is still haunting you because your
new family that you love dearly make no
mistake
that you love dearly doesn't look like
that old picture
and you are still hanging on to that old
picture
while living in another photo
and your body can't reconcile
one foot here and one foot here or more
more damning half your heart here and
half your heart here
right
and
because what we're talking about when it
comes to names is semantics i mean you
could put like the dodgers or whatever
other nonsense team you have there in
los angeles you call it the ponies the
frogs the you know the hip-hop artist i
don't care what you call it it could be
anything
but this isn't about a name
this is about you
not letting dan go
and this is about you not fully being
this is what my family looks like now
and when whatever and the two last name
seven last name who cares about the
names
it's about you leaning into
we have to come up with who we are and
you still see we as but also
him right
and so what i'm telling you is dan will
always have a place in your heart you'll
see his face as those kids get older and
older and older you'll see his attitudes
and the laugh that he had and the eye
crinkles that he had you'll see that
stuff
there and you got to let dan go
right and you have to take ownership of
your new story your new picture your new
whatever this is and then call it
whatever crap you want to
yeah i agree
percent does that ring true still work
for me
it does it does
and i know it seems like semantics and
silly
uh no no no hey a name is powerful right
look at what's happening in russian
ukraine today like you're russians no
we're not right a name is everything
it's so don't hear me be dismissive of
that
yeah but when you come i agree there's
probably more to it i just also have
this other thing going on too what's the
other thing
meaning that
my kids when we say we are the smith
family let's say they they feel left out
when we try to
use one name i guess you know
okay
do they feel that or do you feel that
on their behalf
no definitely my oldest is vocal about
it okay that he feels left out when we
use
the family name that's my husband and
i's name and the baby's name but he
doesn't want to change his name
he doesn't want to change his name and
he in fact when he was very upset that i
was changing my name when i got married
and also um kind of wanted my husband to
change his last name to dan's last name
all
right
how old is this he wasn't gonna happen
eight yeah
so be very careful
about letting an eight-year-old's
feelings dictate yours
right because they're eight and you've
heard me say this a thousand times like
there's a reason why we don't let
eight-year-olds you know drive cars and
buy beer and vote because they're eight
and of course everything in his body and
heart and mind wants to keep things the
way they were i don't want to forget dad
i've got that now i'm gonna hang on to
that and at the same time
um anything that looks new to his little
body is a threat
because everything he knew is different
now everything he knows is different now
and so
i mean i would honor that hug him
through that
and feel those like man i'm i hear that
you feel left out and my heart's broken
and you feel left out because you're a
part of this
just because your name is remaining
jones
you're you're a member of the smith
family
or i like that you're a member of the
joan smith family right with i'll stick
a hyphen in there for you if that's what
you need right but you're here you're in
this gang and in fact here's what's
gonna happen if he's if he follows if he
tracks
he's gonna
pull on the rope he's gonna pull on that
tether and see how tight see if you're
gonna leave too
see if this new guy's gonna leave too
and he's gonna yank and pull and kick
and bite and claw and see if his little
uh muscles
can push away too because it's happened
once before
and that's just his sweet beautiful
little body trying to protect him
oh yeah he definitely does that yeah i
mean it's totally normal it's
heartbreaking and it's awful and that's
the trauma of losing somebody so
important in your life right
and my guess is you probably do the same
thing just differently
right
i don't know what that looks like but
have you ever sat down and written down
a letter yet
oh yeah plenty of times how did that go
tell us about it
it's it's good it's cathartic i mean i
get it from the very beginning like i
said it's been nearly seven years now so
have you ever told him how pissed off
you are adam
oh yeah good time good
so yeah i think continuing to work
through it but
i would love to see you grieve and
have some sort of something where you
let dan go
and
man
it's always gonna be a part of you but
honor your kids and they come up with a
name and if it's the jones typhon smith
name for the for a couple of years okay
i'm not gonna lose sleep over that um
it's more important to do that to the
unity exercise which i mean i would love
to have the joan smith values would be
great
um right and just throw hyphen up there
is that something you all can do
uh yeah i think so
i think so and
here's what would be real important
invite your two young ones dan's kids
invite them to participate in this not
only participate but to take some major
ownership in this who are we all yeah
that's what i like that's what i liked
about it when you talk about it on the
show is having the kids participate have
some buy-in yeah and even if they say
what are some things that um
dan what are some things that your
original what are some things he would
have wanted on this list
because here's the thing
he's
half of your kids are him
right and so man bring him bring dan is
to be a part of this thing and i know
that's like i'm talking out of both
sides of my mouth let him go but your
kids can never let him go half of half
of them is dan right so
what are some things that dan dan dad
would want you to put in here right to
put on this form to to to put as a part
of our values what's something that that
meant values to dad and they may not
know or they may make it up something
they don't have a lot of memories of him
because one's only eight right he's one
years old um but you can bring some
stuff he loved laughter
he loved joy he loved respecting other
people he loved different opinions and
he loved you know wrestle whatever the
things are add those things are let them
know that the other half with that that
rests within them is
strong and good
and you let that half
let him go let him go and then begin to
truly live into that picture that you
have i'm so i'm man i'm makes my heart
feel good that you've been writing the
letters for years that's fantastic
maybe it's time to write the letter that
says it's time for me to let you go
i got two little boys to raise and
another six month old by this other guy
who's pretty awesome by the way but i
met him at work and gross but
here we are in the new story